this is the monkey pox virus now under
global investigation in many countries
cases arising and scientists working to
find out why
leaders around the world alert and
updated on the outbreak
they haven't told me
the level of exposure yet but it is
something that everybody should be
concerned about we're working on it hard
to
figure out what we do
and what
vaccine if any may be available for but
it is a concern in the sense that if it
were to spread it's consequential
that's all they've told me
the virus is usually limited to africa
but clusters of cases have been found in
europe the us canada and australia
and the world health organization
expects monkey pox will spread further
extra surveillance is underway and some
countries introducing restrictions
we must be vigilant clear instructions
have been given to doctors and hospitals
if there are any people who have
symptoms you obviously have to go to the
emergency room immediately
in the us they're testing and contact
tracing after a confirmed case in
massachusetts american health protection
officials are tracking other possible
infections
the uk cases are mostly clustered around
london the first treated here at saint
thomas's hospital the person had
traveled from nigeria but scientists
don't know how subsequent cases are
connected infections are expected to
rise significantly and the uk is
stocking up on smallpox vaccine which
offers some protection
initially we will see more cases just
because we are also now looking for it
for them
and also those people who have had close
contacts with the cases we've now
identified they have that one to three
week incubation period so there will
definitely be more cases potentially in
more locations
despite how it looks monkey pox is
usually mild and not easily spread
even so the current cases are puzzling
scientists and after two years of covert
it's little wonder some are worried
laura bundock sky news